all right, let's see what is on the minds
of some in our audience.
We will go to the phones at (617) 830-4750
starting today with our call or from the seven
four zero area code.
Who's calling today from seven four zero and
a what's on your mind today?
Hi, my name's Chris.
I was actually calling because I noticed that
uh, independent media, right?
So I watched your show and then after, uh,
if I'm on like autoplay, it goes to CNN and
that's NBC.
So I said I wasn't interested in those.
And now it goes to comedy central, the late
shows, you know what I mean?
Right.
Oh yeah.
Now this is on YouTube for people who don't
know.
You're talking about the YouTube suggestions.
Yeah.
Right.
YouTube suggestions.
Um, but if I go to like my eight, I went 80,
so I like atheist content.
It's always the same person in my queue or
someone in the same area.
Right?
So if I want to like, I'll get Lauren Ross
something else.
But depending,
Chris, it sounds like you're talking through
a critical piece of paper, unfortunately.
So it's a completely, the connection has imploded,
so I'm going to let you go.
But this is an important issue.
We've been talking about it.
This is w look, look at our numbers.
95% of the video of the views that YouTube
used to give us by recommending our videos.
When people watch other stuff, those are gone.
They are now going to corporate media.
And when people specifically seek out our
content on YouTube, the up next recommendations
are all CNN, Fox, MSNBC, Seth Meyers, Stephen
Colbert, air.
Um, Trevor.
Noah, et cetera, et cetera programs, you know,
with tens of millions or a hundred million
dollar annual budgets.
It's crazy.
We can't do anything about it.
But, uh, we are, we are doing what we can.
That's a, that's all I can say.